while plenty of Netflix originals have
gotten positive buzz over the last year
some of them have flown under the radar
without much fanfare
if you've already finished hits like
Ozark the crown and narcos then grab
some popcorn settle in and check out
these underrated Netflix originals
created by the showrunner of 2016
awkward coming-of-age series on my block
is equal parts drama comedy and
political commentary the series follows
high school freshmen Monse caesar Jamal
and Reuben as they deal with a diverse
range of challenges in their
south-central Los Angeles neighborhood
from teenage confusion over romantic
relationships to high stakes conflicts
and gang violence the potential for
trouble and a distant sound of gunshots
might always be present in the backdrop
of their neighborhood but thanks to its
knack for empathetic storytelling and
the authentic performances of its
talented cast on my block never begins
to feel like an after-school special
a touch of dark humor and the occasional
tender moment between the characters
manages to balance the heavy subject
matter too with young actors of color
cast in the leading roles and a
storyline that weaves every plot
together without resorting to filler
episodes on my block offers a deeply
affective insight into life in the inner
city while stranger things took a
nostalgic look back of the 80s
everything sucks was inspired by teen
comedy tropes which grew out of the
following decade so if you consider
yourself a 90s kid you might be able to
relate to the struggle of highschool
misfits like Kate Luc McQuaid tyler and
emmalin kind of fairytale world is
Alanis Morissette live in Canada set in
the real aptly named small town of
boring Oregon in 1996 everything sucks
follows a group of outcasts in the a/v
and drama clubs who decide to make a
movie together after the school play is
canceled meanwhile Luke struggles with
his relationship with his estranged
father Kate slowly comes out to her
friends and family and Tyler finds
himself wondering why he can't seem to
land a date the series stars several
fresh faces including Jahi Winston as
Luke and Quinn Liebling as Tyler
alongside more familiar names like
Sydney Sweeney as Emily with a realistic
storyline a heaping of nineties cultural
references and a charming cast
everything sucked makes for something of
a single season gem set on a remote
Welsh Island in 1905 the terrifying
period drama apostle follows Thomas
Richardson as he attempts to rescue his
sister Jennifer from a secretive
religious cults in order to prize some
secrets out of cult members who might be
willing to reveal more than they should
Thomas disguises himself as a curious
convert and eventually finds out that
Jennifer is being held for ransom from
there a gruesome battle for the future
of the island ensues and if you get a
bit squeamish at the sight of blood well
you may want to keep your eyes shut but
while apostle might be gory it's not for
mere shock value this film is a bonafide
psychological thriller all the way
through this please this community it's
broken that was such the fascinating
mythology built around the cult explores
the dark side of the Divine Feminine and
the open-ended conclusion will it once
satisfy viewers and leave them pondering
kiss me first is an experimental series
which alternates between the real and
the surreal as it flips from live-action
to virtual reality Laila is a lonely
teenager who spends most of her days
playing the MMORPG azana
in which she meets a more confident girl
named test who pulls her out of her
shell the two eventually become close
offline but when test disappears laila
takes it upon herself to solve the
mystery and quickly learns that virtual
actions can have real-world consequences
the series is based on the Lottie Moga
novel of the same title and with skin's
creator Brian else Lee at the helm you
just know you're in for plenty of juicy
drama no supposed to be cruel I'm not
I'm a friend and I'm here
kiss me first has echoes of Black Mirror
another sci-fi series which explored the
pitfalls of human reliance on technology
and its uncanny valley style of CGI
makes it hard not to question your own
relationship to your screens you might
want to spend a little time outside
after this one based on the novel of
Cornelia by Florencia at Chevy's hair
DITA is a solid thriller that begins by
inviting the viewer into a setting that
establishes a genuine sense of impending
doom and then establishes a tone which
never quite lets up throughout the rest
of the film pipa a policewoman whose
friend pinellia went missing in
Patagonia as a teenager feels like she
can't find peace until she solves the
mystery behind her disappearance but
she sets out to discover what really
happened to her friend on that fateful
day she realizes that the search might
be putting her own life in danger
although the plot can drag a bit during
the scenes in which people in gross tin
paperwork he'll still remain gripped
until the very last moment
[Music]